I came across an insight that I think is
a very useful frame very useful lens
through which to make sense of chaotic
and potentially unpredictable situations
things we didn't see coming
always sideline us all disruption by
definition was a surprise it wasn't in
our Maps wasn't part of our calculations
otherwise we would have mitigated
against it and it would have never been
a disruption so by definition a
disruption always has to be a surprise
and it always has to be a kind of
annihilation to the status quo
disruption forces a reaction and there's
something called homeostatic capacity
which is the resiliency built into our
system has individual organisms and as
collectives and as societies right it's
like that rocky line that says it's not
how many punches you give but how many
punches you can receive and get back up
again and so homeostatic capacity is our
capacity to bounce back from disruption
and usually our homeostatic capacity
catalyzes radical innovation right when
things are predictable in the status quo
rules there can be no innovation because
there's no incentive to change what's
working if it's not broke why fix it and
so you get a kind of astanga me into as
you say in Spanish and get set in your
ways you get overly comfortable you get
lazy right this is the innovators
dilemma once his business model works he
stops innovating and so disruption
first of all should be welcomed but we
should always accept that disruption is
never something that we can really plan
for because by definition it has to be
something that takes us by surprise but
when it does happen the one thing that
we can do is embrace and stop clinging
to a dying world or a dying business
model or a dying way of doing things and
just embrace the disruption as a chance
for the manifestation of the following
quote there are decades where nothing
happens and there are weeks when decades
how exciting event to be witness to a
death and a resurrection we get to
practice resurrection but only after we
die and what's ironic that that happens
to many people is okay right so
disruption can be planned for and so
it's futile to try to prepare for
disruption other than to practice dying
and resurrection in your sort of daily
life you know but ironically is that
when disruption does strike when that
thing that we didn't see coming does
take us by surprise and changes
everything immediately people against to
start to pretend that they know what's
coming right once their maps are pierced
they immediately make new maps about the
new situation so like right now the
world is being disrupted by kovat and
all of a sudden people are saying all
this virus is going to be with us
forever Oh for the next ten years people
aren't gonna travel though this industry
will never be the same again first of
all people don't know right and a
rapidly changing world by definition
are no Maps there can only be a compass
and this is true because of the
following amazing lens that started this
reflection the paradoxical logic of
strategy the reason you can't have a map
the reason you can't have a strategy to
deploy is that the system is dynamic
right for every action there is an equal
and opposing reaction so you can have a
map that tells you where you're gonna go
but that map is static and the world is
dynamic and so by the paradoxical logic
of strategy the minute you deploy a
strategy the system responds and adapts
to that strategy like organisms learning
to fight against antibiotics and so it's
it's a fool's errand to try to make
plans to try to make maps that are
accurately reliable eventually by the
paradoxical logic of strategy all maps
fall by the wayside evolution happens
disruption happens the sidelining
of all
happens and it is our capacity to
practice resurrection that gets us
really looking because we must be
willing to let go of the life we've
planned so that we can live the life
that is waiting for says mr. Joseph camp
and so perhaps this is the legs right
this but but for the grace of God go
wean of this moment this is the this is
the the leap of faith that we must take
right this is this is the the willing
surrender and the and the willing
acceptance and the enthusiastic embrace
of a shift we didn't see coming but that
was as inevitable as every disruption
that engenders transformation and
innovation it's just evolution it's just
what's happening and so by the paradox
of the logic of strategy perhaps we can
stop trying to know and simply embrace
the whole mystery with little more
we need a little more grace you know
this is how we take the road less
traveled by and that will make all the
difference
this is it this is a human story this is
how we this is how we break on through
to the other side
if you cannot submit you cannot die and
if you cannot die
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
sit with that
[Music]